let's get right to it
tom brady
announces today on instagram just before
9 a.m eastern that he is not returning
to the new england patriots he said in
the post he doesn't know what his
football future holds which implies he
doesn't know what his next destination
will be but you know chris
you and i have both had this nagging
sense that at the end of the day he's
going to find his way back to new
england especially when it looks like
there's going to be no off season
program
but man it was sudden it was surprising
and
see you later tom brady 20 years later
he's going to go somewhere else
yeah well it's shocking it is i i did in
my in my heart of hearts thought
ultimately he would end up back in new
england you know for some deal that
seemed to work out for both sides you
know the one thing i've learned about
the situation a little bit you know and
i i was i i became aware of it yesterday
you know somebody with some knowledge of
the situation had told me oh they
thought it could be very hard to have
any wiggle room with tom brady and the
contract and as far as money and maybe
throwing more money in his direction
once they signed devin mccourty and then
i think once they had a franchise tag
joe thuney it just took away some more
wiggle room from the new england
patriots to get back a guy like tom
brady but it's sad mike i mean it's the
end of an era it really is this is uh
one of the coolest greatest runs i've
ever seen in my lifetime in sports
history it's been that special and it's
in a sport where everything was supposed
to be equal i have the ultimate respect
for belichick and of course the ultimate
respect for tom brady i mean he was my
idol for a long long time and i still
really look up to him
yeah and look
it's not an easy situation to get to the
end of the road after 20 years i don't
think anybody expects and can reasonably
predict that a relationship will last
that long 20 years is an eternity in
football when
every team is a different organism each
and every year to think that brady has
been there for 20 different iterations
of the patriots is stunning and i spoke
to robert kraft today by phone about it
and he explained that tom went over to
his house last night and said he's going
to be moving on and robert craft's
attitude is exactly what it needs to be
i got 20 years out of this guy i got six
super bowl championships out of this guy
he deserves his freedom if he wants it
robert kraft pointed out he's very sad
about it he's going to support tom brady
except when he plays the patriots if and
when that happens and what a game
that'll be
but
look the guy has earned the right to go
elsewhere if that's what he wants to do
plain and simple and it seems that's
what he wants to do chris and now we
have to figure out where he's going to
go that's the next phase in all this and
i don't think anybody knows with any
certainty where this one is going to end
up
well yeah i don't i mean and then you
know the bradycraft relationship is as
special as it gets you know as far as
owner player that we've ever seen and
you know again i think you know when
this is all said and done and cooler
heads prevail you know i think belichick
brady kraft they're all going to get
together and realize how special this
run was that they created
i do think that time will come i'm sure
there's a little bit bitterness right
now between a belichick and a brady
that's just the way it goes but the big
thing is too i mean let's not forget and
i know it's finally struck tom brady
which is sad because he's like
synonymous with the new england patriots
i mean it almost looks like you know his
profile of his head is the the patriot
guy on the helmet i mean it's how
synonymous he is to that team to me but
the patriots are the patriots because
they've been making decisions like this
for the last 20 years and it just
finally struck tom brady which none of
us really wanted to see but this is the
part of their greatness of knowing when
to get rid of players when to move on
and even for a great like tom brady i
think they realized that man the re the
the rewards not worth the risk and the
price tag not worth what they're going
to get out of the play at the age of 43
and they're trying to build for the
future and stay on top of the sport
and that's the other thing too chris
look and i wonder how much other teams
are influenced by
the perception that bill belichick was
ready to move on he's seen the guy for
20 years and only bill belichick and
josh mcdaniel the offensive coordinator
know brady's performance relative to the
expectations relative to the play that's
been called relative to the options that
are there
to
throw the ball to this guy or that guy
is he getting through the progressions
is he moving the way he needs to is he
making the right decisions and
you know now's the time and bill
belichick has always been the guy who
likes to make the move one year too
early instead of one year too late and
with all this talk about tom having the
right to move on and robert kraft truly
wanting him to stay
we can't overlook the very real
possibility if not probability that
belichick decided it's time to move on
and it's not going to be hard for tom
brady to pick that up in his
interactions with belichick that he's
really not all that keen on continuing
so fine off i go and i think that when
the story's finally written on this
that's what the message will be that
belichick was ready to move on
yeah i i know and i don't know if that's
necessarily fair i do think you know i
think belichick from everything you read
connecting dots things i know about the
situation i think he was willing to have
brady back but it was going to be at a
price that he felt still helped the
football team
and i think that probably didn't set
well with brady and brady's camp they
probably wanted a little bit more money
out of respect and what he's done there
but as we talk about in the sport all
the time you know you can't give
contracts to guys for what they have
done you need to give big money to for
guys for what they are going to do
and that's that's a big part of this too
and like i said i think what really
squashed it and and stopped any wiggle
room to where the patriots could maybe
throw an extra three million dollars or
four million dollars into the pot for
brady you know i think unexpectedly i
don't think they expected to franchise
tank thoony i think they thought they
were going to get a deal done and then
the signing of mccourty i think kind of
handcuffed them a little bit to uh be
able to throw a little extra money
brady's way and then probably brady
realized that i'm sure belichick was
very upfront about the situation and
brady decided hey the hell with this i'm
going to go somewhere else the big thing
is mike i mean where does he go
what happens i mean the only thing we
know is tampa in the chargers and
i just i don't know i've had you know
one i don't know if i really think
tampa's a good mix with him there you
know and then the other thing i just
people in the know have told me they
just thought brady would be reluctant to
go to the west coast unless it wasn't
the 49ers okay and that's where i just
look at it right now and goes what what
happens in this uh the next step with
the brady saga
yeah i agree with you completely and
look chris at a certain level like my
first reaction when i saw the two-page
post on social media from tom brady was
he's trying to get the upper hand in the
looming effort to blame someone for tom
brady no longer being a patriot and
patriots fans have been watching and
waiting as to who's going to get the
blame
i think the other side of it too i think
there's a chance he's trying to goose
the market a little bit because i think
a lot of people around the league still
believe he's going back to new england
so why am i going to put together an
offer that he's going to take back to
new england and say hey here's what this
team is willing to do here's what that
team's willing to do what are you
willing to do and bill belichick
eventually says i'll do this they work
out a deal and the team wasted its time
now it's obvious he's in play
if you want him come get him and to the
extent that shefty was talking about
teams laying in weight the other night
now it's clear now it's obvious and
let's put it all together on the
timeline noon eastern yesterday the
window opens for teams to chase him
nobody really chased him there was no
news of anyone chasing him so we get to
the next morning and he says he's
leaving and i think at a certain level
he's trying to get teams to take
seriously that he's leaving and to
understand that now is the time to act
and that's going to drive interest
that's going to drive up the offers and
that's going to allow him to figure out
which team is the best fit for him if he
wants to try to win super bowl number
seven as soon as this year
well
maybe mike maybe but i do think you know
most of the league realized that new
england was not going to make him a deal
that was going to blow you know his
doors off or below the nfl you know uh
media circuit where they were like oh my
gosh they offered brady this type of
money i think people know he was there
to be had you're right i think there was
a sense that he might go back there no
matter what you know for a hometown type
of deal as far as the patriots are
concerned you know but here's the other
thing i think people are missing here a
little bit all right you know when you
sign brady
you know hey it's great it's tom brady
he's a legend you're gonna sell tickets
and billboards it's gonna be a
distraction to your team it's gonna
overtake your facility it's going to be
the only thing in town you know a lot of
teams are i think they look at it and go
oh tom brady's good and then they think
about some of those aspects added to the
fact that oh wait he's 43 and we might
only have him for a year and be right
back in this boat next year okay let
alone here's something a coach said to
me about the situation yesterday he
thought that some coaches were a little
scared of brady to a degree too mike
because he's so used to seeing things
the way they're done in new england and
with belichick and how perfect they are
and how the tees are crossed and the
eyes are always dotted and everything is
just this well-oiled machine certainly
the greatest well-oiled machine i've
ever seen and i think a lot of people
who've been in different facilities
would tell you and i think that
intimidates some organizations to where
they go
wait if he sees how you know we're
making the donuts behind the scenes here
he might be like man you guys are lazy
you're not detailed this is not how you
do it and i think that scares some teams
too with the tom brady uh situation as
well
and chris he's got no opportunity to
kick the tires to the extent that he was
thinking about doing a tour or having
the tour come to him that's all
prohibited by the nfl's covid19 rules
we're going to talk about those coming
up here but
he's going to have to make his decision
sight unseen this is brock osweiler to
the texans type territory and there is a
chance he goes to a team and he's like
holy crap what is wrong with these
people it's almost like the reverse of
odell beckham jr where beckham seems to
be craving
a team like the patriots to help him win
because he's experienced teams that
aren't like that and he can't wait to
get to that kind of an organization
brady has been there for 20 years and it
could be a rude awakening when he goes
to a new team and he's like my god no
wonder this team has sucked all these
years so uh that's
that's a very real dynamic here and okay
let's try to identify the teams then the
chargers and the buccaneers are the two
that we
knew about
raiders have marcus mariota
i don't think that puts them in play for
brady does it are they going to get
brady and throw carr overboard and have
mariota as the backup i don't think so
i don't think so either i don't see that
being a possibility plus you know just
like we talked about i just don't think
the raiders are quite there yet for
brady to feel like i want to come and
join that team you know the bucks and
chargers there is potential there for
the team now we just got to see the
bucks do it all right and you know hey
bruce arians you know he's a good
offense of mine there's some weapons
there we know the defense has some
potential you know there's some
potential for the bucks to be one of
those teams this year we say oh watch
out same with the chargers i mean we
know that defense is top-notch but
really in my heart of hearts and just
from things i know around the league i
don't think there's anybody else i think
this is it
and you know i just i i really do
question at this point right now is
brady going to be willing to go down to
tampa or live across the country with
the la chargers move his family have to
do things like that that's where i think
it's really fascinating and you know i i
i just um uh i'm really i'm really
intrigued to see what happens here
because in my heart of hearts i want to
say brady might just say forget it i'm
going to retire now i guess that's what
i'm trying to say
well and
he he's made it clear he's gonna play
this year he's already signed that check
and i guess circumstances can change but
look
okay now that he's in play and now that
there can be no misunderstanding and no
one can say ah he's just gonna shop our
offer back to bill belichick is there
another team that can pop up out of the
blue tom curran and i were on pft live
talking about this earlier today and we
were both talking about the dolphins and
the dolphins haven't gone away when all
we've ever gotten from steven ross the
owner of the team and brian flores the
head coaches why would he want to come
here that doesn't mean they don't want
him that doesn't mean he doesn't want to
be there and i think we have to take
them seriously especially the extent if
there's any acrimony between belichick
and brady hey this is the brett favre go
to a team in the division and stick it
to the packers twice a year mentality
now not that the dolphins can stick it
twice a year to the patriots but you
know what they were sticking it to him
about once a year on average over the
past several years so who knows and now
they have kyle van noy and byron jones
and eric flowers and seem to be ready to
spend their money and use their draft
picks maybe there is an attraction there
chris and you know it's miami we've
talked about this before giselle bunchen
not boondin boonchin you've mastered
that one uh now that now that uh he's in
play you know she's got a saying where
they're going to live and i think if she
was going to pick anywhere on the map it
would be miami i just think we need to
take the dolphin seriously and we need
to be thinking about other teams that
may say holy crap he really isn't going
back we need to get in on this
yeah i get it and i mean miami makes
sense in a lot of different ways you
know it just doesn't make sense to me
for team building purposes for the miami
dolphins that's where i look at it i
mean are you really giving a lot 60
million dollars to tom brady and i
understand roll the red carpet out right
now as you're trying to actually build
something in this new brian flores era
that to me would be questionable and
again i do think that miami would
probably roll out the red carpet for
brady give them a lot of money treat
them and give him respect maybe that
he's craving a little bit that he didn't
get in new england
but it's still a rebuilding process and
they are
most likely going to draft a quarterback
uh and you know does brady really help
that development of that young
quarterback i don't know i mean those
are a lot of things you got to think
about there to me where i just can't see
that happening i get it you know the
other team i'll throw out there mike
that you know might make sense because
it's a little bit no win now but he
doesn't fit maybe the offense i mean
does chicago want to flirt with tom
brady i mean that would be other team i
just throw out there
i andy dalton nick foles teddy
bridgewater the names we've heard linked
to the chicago bears i mean if they're
looking to upgrade over mitchell
trubisky you go get tom brady and you
make the offense fit him i agree with
you completely that is a team that needs
to be thinking about brady and brady
needs to be looking at that team and
look cold weather he can play in the
cold weather no big deal he'll be fine
the defense is good enough the question
is can they make the offense fit him
will matt and aggie be willing to do
that but nagi has seen what brady can do
from his time with the chiefs and and i
think that that is one team that maybe
wasn't taking brady leaving seriously
that maybe should and maybe should
adjust their plans accordingly
yeah well i mean you know again
it makes a lot of sense they have a lot
of pieces in place
they have a borderline super bowl
defense as is
right the big question i think there
would be yeah can nagi can negi conform
right and get away from some of the
movement stuff he does with the
quarterback and implement things that
brady wants to do and you know if it
came down to chicago when brady breaks
down chicago and he'll probably watch
film with him is he gonna like their off
men's too and i think that's
questionable i think he's gonna look at
it and go man i don't really like this
uh it looked crappy last year and i'm
not so sure how they'll conform the
offense around me do they have those
tools in their toolbook to do that so
that would be just the negatives but i
mean just on paper as far as need you
know city spotlight you know team having
some certain things in place they feel
like you know i i you know i could see
that being a possibility but we've heard
no rumors or anything like that uh with
those two to this point
and the one last team i'll mention the
possibility that jerry jones rolls out
of bed on any given day and says enough
with dak prescott trying to stick us up
for 35 million a year or more let's go
get tommy let's try to win the super
bowl let's do this thing
a guy can dream because that would be
one of the great stories of all time if
that would work out although the chances
of it happening i think are incredibly
slim
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports